reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution
[Musik]
nun erfüllt diese firma welches tat aber
ich bin nicht mehr da zenit ist die
fünfte firma zero führe die fünfte
herausforderung und die letzte der
erfolgsverwöhnte unternehmer jean claude
biver nimmt sein letztes jahr ein stück
in angriff zum auftakt der uhrenmesse
treffe ich den manager multimillionär
ehemann und familienvater
das ist die eigentlich für sie besonders
wichtig
und auch wenn wir nicht genug nach noch
sechs sieben jahren die sich für den 70
die 75 werde ich ein bisschen weniger
ich möchte nicht abwehren ich möchte die
zukunft schauen
wissen sie ich will nicht da hinten
schauen ich will mal horn
was treibt den 68-jährigen anstatt in
ruhestand zu genießen mindestens doppelt
so viel zu arbeiten wie ein
durchschnittlicher arbeitnehmer davon
handelt dieser film ist ein privileg
hier zu sein
die erste base messe mit über 83 oder 4
883 haben am camping bus geschlafen
hinter werden güterbahnhof da gibt es
einen kleinen park und da haben wir
geschlafen im campingbus und jeden
morgen zum bahnhof und dann für einen
frankly eine dusche genommen
der große wagen machte der letzte aber
immer dieselbe freude
wissen sie egal welchen weg sie tun die
freude muss bleiben oder sie muss sich
vergrößert erfolgshungrig scheint er
ohne scheu ein weiteres kräftemessen in
der hart umkämpften branche einzugehen
wir haben viel wettbewerb man muss etwas
erreichen überleben
das ist wie wenn die sport treibe der
wettbewerb für mich im sport ist dass
ich an meine limite komme das heißt mit
meinem gewicht mann der größer soll ich
eher im flachland velofahrer aber ich
gebe gas raus obwohl ich nicht dafür
geeignet bin aber ich habe die
schwierigkeit geben ich kämpfe gerne ich
erreiche gerne etwas
in dieser einen woche muss er zwei
drittel des jahresumsatzes aufgleisen
wie wehrleiter die uhren sparte des
weltgrößten luxuskonzerns lvmh tag heuer
und hublot hat er bereits auf die
erfolgsspur geleitet sein letzter coup
gilt der cenit ich war mir nicht mehr
gewöhnt mit so kleinen machten mit so
wenigen mitteln es bin ich fast wieder
im campingbus das heißt sehen die die
szesik sie dies thema kleiner zyklon 20
mal kleiner als treuer und da muss man
sich anpassen kann man nicht mit
denselben mitteln unterwegs sei
das macht die sache schwierig und es ist
auch schwierig wegen meinem druck der
das ist die letzte machte die ich führen
will und ich will nicht dass das ein
misserfolg ist denn der letzte schritt
bis erfolg sein
jede firma sollte ein stilo haben wie
ricardo und einen präsidenten wie mich
immer im mittelpunkt scheint sich biwak
einer einlage zu schade
doch der erfolgsdruck fordert seinen
tribut
bis heute 8
und da du machst du heute abend versuche
ich auch sehr wenig zu essen
sonst kann man nicht diese sieben tagen
voll dabei sein
man muss wenig essen und viel trinken
und kein alkohol natürlich viva und sie
nicht beide benötigen denn erfolg um die
uhren babys anzupreisen holt sich bieber
prominente unterstützung schmieds der
musikproduzent und ehemann von alicia
keys soll den verkauf ankurbeln
denn ein guter verkäufer kann verkaufen
von dem er nicht überzeugung
ich kann nur meine überzeugung ihnen
verkaufen handelte sind anti magnetik
handelt prozent an die thermik handelt
prozent chronometer certified by bis o
also sind vorbilder braut
foto buccino nirgendwo ist limit nein
die kubaner haben uns gesagt wenn du den
gipfel des berges erreicht dann klettere
weiter sie sagen sprichwort vom tibet
ich glaube natürlich glaube ich trage es
gibt kein gipfel der einzige gipfel gibt
es bei meinem und dann muss ich alles
erreicht haben so und manager vokabular
geringen teil des business
trotzdem frage ich mich ob hinter
beavers engagement nicht mehr steckt als
ein plumper verkaufstrick sind die uhren
seine wahre liebe sein lebenselexier ich
werde heute schlafen träumen wie ein
junger mann und morgen arbeite ich wie
ein junger mann
danke dass sich heute haben den einen
jungen mann verwandelt haben
personal brauchen raum um ein offenes
system mit dennoch eine musik wie das
funktioniert
es ist ein geben und nehmen im lachen
und das ist beim bau ums leben der tag
war unglaublich positiv das heißt man
hätte nicht besser diese messe starten
können als bei solch einem tag alles
ging richtig
einiges war improvisiert aber die
improvisation war positiv und die
stimmung hat bestimmt das heißt die
stimmung ist sehr gut und jetzt stand er
ist er ja der also beim zuerst muss ich
diese zweiter zwölf mails beantworten
ich kann ja nicht schlafen geben 205 ps
die nicht erledigt sind
das heißt es in 12 212 leute denen ich
jetzt nicht geantwortet habe ich kann
nicht schlafen geht oder diese leute zu
beantworten und das ist natürlich da
brauche ich zwei stunden ja um 2 uhr ins
bett
nachtschicht ist alltag für jean claude
biver um 5 uhr treffe ich ihn in seiner
villa am genfer see bereits tief
versunken in der arbeit während die
familie noch schläft diese arbeitsweise
verdankt er einem ehemaligen regierungs
und späteren bundesrat ja 35 jahre habe
ich das jetzt gemacht aber es wurde mir
von der hat mir eines tages um fünf uhr
morgens ein termin gegeben da sich ins
büro kam sagte er mir weißt du warum
finden wir hier bist ja ich komme wegen
anders oder nein du bist hier
5 denn du musst rechnen wenn du jeden
tag zwei stunden mehrarbeit ist als
dauerkonkurrent wer nur 300 tage das
gibt 600 stunden dividiert durch 40
stunden pro woche das sind 14 15 wochen
deswegen bist du hier
denn 15 wochen vorsprung kannst du
nehmen wenn du nur zwei stunden pro tag
mehr arbeit ist es war sieben minuten
nach fünf ich war draußen und seitdem
stehe ich jeden morgen fünf worauf heute
natürlich ist ein teil erfolg ist zuerst
mal arbeit im zweiten arbeit und
drittens arbeit und nummer vier hilfe
und nummer fünf bisschen kreativität
aber auch weitere sexy ist 80 prozent
von von alle befolgen
man muss arbeiten und ich habe das große
glück privileg
dass man allein schafft auch mal der
arbeit ist das weiß ich es gibt kein
wochenende die meisten leute waren
wochenende um wieder etwas anderes zu
tun und arbeiten und ich mit meiner
leidenschaft ich habe ja nie den
eindruck dass ich arbeite dass das
treibt mich an
[Musik]
für seine zweite frau sandra und den
gemeinsamen sohn pierre reserviert jean
claude biver die frühstückszeit
die familie habe einen hohen stellenwert
in seinem leben trotzdem nach einem
kurzen café müssen alle los bis bald das
bedeutet erst später am abend wird
bieber wieder zu hause eintreffen
[Musik]
ob sie sich nicht gewünscht hat mehr
zeit mit ihrem mann zu verbringen wenn
er das pensionsalter erreicht hat würde
ich gerne wissen
natürlich hätte ich mir das gewünscht
vor allen dingen ich meine wir wir
verstehen uns extrem gut
aber er kann die sache natürlich nicht
halb machen das heißt er wird sich drei
hundertprozentigen seiner arbeit weil
lerne ethiker die auch überdimensional
ist und von der warte aus gesehen ich
hätte natürlich nicht gedacht dass er so
viel arbeitet aber das ist nun mal so
und wenn er es tut unterstütze ich ihn
trennen und das das beste was ich machen
kann
ich begebe mich mit jean claude biver
zurück zu den anfängen seiner karriere
ins vallée de joux
90 von peter ufer hat sie verschlagen
auch im studium warum warum sind sie da
auf wo ja die natur die authentizität
die ruhe und nicht nein ich habe keine
ahnung von meinem job
ich bin sofort im studio und bin hierher
gekommen wenn ich hab gesagt hier will
ich wohnen und was machen
ich wollte lehrer seien in der schule
die uhrmacherschule und das wurde
natürlich nichts
das war der anfang eigentlich ein
glücklicher zufall
ich bin ein glücklicher mensch ich
bekomme mein glück glück glück wie
andere bekommen regeln so bekomme ich
das glück war auf der spur vor ihrem
glück das vallée de joux guten tag jetzt
gut ja und ihnen ja ich habe doch
gedacht dass sie das sehen ja ja ich
bin's kaum einen steinwurf entfernt
liegt die was meisterstück blut
innerhalb von zehn jahren hat er die
firma von 20.000 auf 60 millionen
aufgewertet verkauft hatte sie 1992
wie lange ist das her 30 jahre 20.30
genial brutto grüßt sie auch wie geht es
ihnen
sind sie noch da fantastisch sie haben
die fabrik um mich herum gebaut
ich war noch nicht drin ich wage es
nicht einzutreten
danke für alles was sie machen
neben blonder werden im vallée de joux
welt marken wie gerard piqué oder präge
hergestellt das abgelegene tal ist das
epizentrum der schweizer luxusuhren
industrie zuerst habe ich angefangen zu
lieben die gegend aber die gegend das
war in digital
das prägt eine mentalität der menschen
also ich habe angefangen das klima und
die gegen zu lieben
dann habe ich angefangen die menschen
zuliebe
und dann habe ich angefangen den job der
menschen die sind ja alle uhrmacher hier
an mit abstand des bäckers und der
metzger dann habe ich angefangen die den
job der menschen zu lieben und so billig
zu uhrmacherkunst dass sie ist einen
totalen weg von der gegend zu den
menschen und von den menschen zum doc
rivers letzter streich er will der cenit
zu neuem glanz verhelfen
in der blütezeit der firma arbeiteten
hier 2000 angestellte heute sind es
gerade noch 200 ihnen überbringt bieber
die jüngsten verkaufszahlen der basler
messe
der manager mit milliardenumsatz sucht
die direkte begegnung mit der
belegschaft die bodenhaftung hat er
nicht verloren
profumo
das habe ich da das podest müsst ihr
baby das podest
nein ich steige doch nicht auf ein
podest
2017 war eine gute messe wir haben
mehrere zehntausend uhren verkauft für
mehr als 40 millionen franken das heißt
ein plus von 32 prozent gegenüber 2016
sie werden sehen beginnt sie nicht den
gebührenden platz in der geschichte der
mechanischen namen zurück anbieters
arbeitsweise mussten sich die cenit
angestellten gewinnen woche werde
gesichter freuen
er hat einfach alles vergessen aber mit
wem gegangen was koalition trotz
technologiewandel ist bei zenit
handarbeit noch immer gefragt fast alle
bestandteile werden hier gefertigt daran
will auch der chef nicht rütteln
zum glück in 42 jahre musste ich nur
einmal leute entlassen
einmal 49 leute das war bei tag heuer
2014 einmal in 42 jahre ist nicht viel
aber es war peinlich warum wenn sie eine
person entlassen
wie viele leute wären davon konsequenten
haben die kinder die freunde die eltern
also eine person die man hat lässt gibt
konsequenten und 30 leute und das muss
man manchmal die richtige vor sowas tun
der staat mit zenit scheint geglückt
bis der erfolg gesichert ist sind aber
noch ein paar jahre geduld gefragt
und wenn sie jetzt gerade werdet sterben
dann würde ich sagen es tut mir leid
dass ich nicht kalt zeit hatte um alles
zurückzugeben
aber ich habe wenigstens werden meinem
leben das beste getan und ich habe mich
benommen auf eine art und weise von der
ich stolz sein kann und kann mich in den
spiegel schauen wie wir das gemacht da
hat es nicht genügend zeit um es fit zu
machen und du hattest du hast du hast
das gemacht
wir begleiten den wahlschweizer in sein
heimatland luxemburg dass er vor 60
jahren verlassen hat er ist auf promo
tour im handgepäck seine frisch
gedruckte biografie seine erfahrungen
und erkenntnisse weiterzugeben ist teil
seines lebens konzeptes du kannst alles
wenn du nur willst dass es nicht ganz so
einfach und eine steile karriere nicht
allen möglich ist weiß auch schon claude
biver
ja ich glaube dann gegessen werden muss
ich glaube jeder hat das recht zu
glauben dass er in die zukunft
mit der voll gehen kann aber ich weiß
auch dass es ungerecht ist meinte alle
leute sieht nicht geboren mit dem selben
chancen
aber egal wie man geboren ist man müsste
ständig trotzdem optimistisch bleibt
solange man lebt kann man etwas
erreichen nicht unbedingt auf dem niveau
den man sich gewünscht hätte aber etwas
kann erreicht und was man immer rechnen
kann ist liebe lieber kann jeder geben
mit dem star rummel in seiner heimat hat
er nicht gerechnet
jawohl das ist das war ja das ziel des
buches dass es den jungen menschen den
jungen unternehmern mut optimismus und
visionen gibt es ist kurz vor 22 uhr als
wir uns auf den heimweg machen
billie jean claude biver dieses tempo
wirklich noch sieben jahre durchhalten
ich fühle mich jetzt nicht mehr
aber vielleicht werde ich trotzdem ein
bisschen schlafen in flugzeugen
mache ich mir nicht
ich bin ich jedoch für sich noch pokale
weder kopf
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution